ça va les jeunes ont-ils je danse mieux
que toi ça va la diversité des fruits la
mjc de bobigny n'a ici c'est l'élite
alors ça dégage et tout le monde
ah et puis vous me verrez cet escalier
là qui m'a coûté un endroit un patois
léo attends tu vas vous c'était bien
juste trop bien comme ça dans ses lada
jaune c'est moi
c'est beau c'est à toi que j'embrasse
c'est le tatouage jackel hd aux 25 ans
21 ans d'écart se voit ça choquera
personne ici vincent allez tu m'attends
l'âge j'ai des contrats de faire signer
ou alors non qui court lui signera dans
ma chambre d'hôtel sera plus simple vote
steiner bonsoir
mademoiselle pour sa part benoît z on
sabre dames et si bonsoir messieurs de
tisons un bracelet électronique
bon réécoutez bienvenue à bienvenue à la
dernière ça la 45e de cours
la 45e
cérémonie des césar je suis très
heureuse d'être là enfin très heureuse
non le pôle mots qui prédomine
à droite sentiment premier heureusement
je suis on va dire je suis très bas je
suis créé je suis très courageuse d'être
là parce que non
[Musique]
elle a bien choisi son année ils furent
est-il pour faire son retour pas ça
s'appelle le pixel s'est dit 2020 c'est
pour moi bien sûr
oui parce que moi j'ai accepté il ya
très longtemps c'était bien avant la
tempête
alors au début je voulais pas [ __ ]
j'aurais dû rester là dessus je le
savais je ne sentais pas que c'est à
dire j'ai dit non j'ai dit non écoutez
vous êtes gentil mais je ne refait
jamais deux fois la même chose
j'ai déjà fait une question de principe
one ils ont insisté gilles hinhinhin le
nombre de questions ils ont dit leur
avancée en cassel dans la salle j'ai dit
oui il faut absolument que le fasse qui
d'autres attaques d'amendé voilà
pourquoi je suis là alors bizarrement
cette année contrairement à il ya quatre
ans j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup de
messages de soutien
énormément d'encouragements de la part
des gens du métier c'est très gentil
beaucoup beaucoup de textos aux les gens
qui sont à la peine
bonne chance et bon courage on est avec
toi
enfin on ne sera pas dans la salle mais
on est avec toi ont pensé perd pas
espoir tu vas t'on sortir je me suis
passé un petit y est reine parce que je
veux non mais j'ai eu l'impression d'un
cancer franchement mais tous les
marqueurs est au rouge vous dire on m'a
refusé un crédit à la banque
ça a pris des proportions cette histoire
là mes proches se sont inquiétés pour
moi j'ai commencé à recevoir des fleurs
à l'approché de la cérémonie des des
chocolats je veux dire c'est même une
cagnotte litchi qui s'est ouvert il
paraît si en soutien dans 112 euros on a
collecté déjà pour rester en vie foresti
ça s'appelle si vous voulez participer
et puis alors même dans la rue les gens
m'arrêtaient les gens que je connaissais
pas ça se voyait apparemment il aimait
vous avez l'air fatigué vous avez maigri
évidemment que j'ai maigri connard ça
fait quinze jours je m'alimente plus
comme toutes les actrices ici présentes
pour entrer dans la danse ou du tout
simplement voilà ça va les filles
savaient pas trop faim
on crève la dalle 1 ce soir on se lâche
un mcdo kebab double dose sauce blanche
oignons ont fait péter les agrafes 1 on
est d'accord
d'ailleurs j'en profite tomba à temps
j'en profite qu il ya des créateurs dans
la salle je crois de mode puisque je
crois que olivier rousteing est là alors
j'en profite messieurs les stylistes
pour vous rappeler l'existence de d'un
élément vous avez sans doute omis qui
s'appelle le ventre et qui cite voilà
c'est situe entre les seins et le bassin
et ce à une fonction digestive ou
respiratoires voilà donc si vous pouviez
les intégrer dans vos créations les
prochaines fois alors non je sais ça
marche
non je sais que ça va dénaturer vos
croquis mais pensez-y c'est une fonction
vitale
bref donc vous l'aurez compris l
approche de la cérémonie la ces derniers
mois j'ai vécu une comment dire comme
une expérience de fin de vie par
anticipation
non mais c'est pas désagréable
franchement je je je je le conseille à
tout le monde ça permet de faire des
petites répètes quoi ça permet de se
projeter puis puis ça permet de faire le
tri dans tes relations moi je moi je
sais qui sera présent le jour du grand
départ et qui se contentera d'un pouce
en bas sur instagram un je vous lis un
peu je peux réserver l'église on sera
pas sur une cathédrale on sera plutôt
sur une chapelle en termes de jauge
bref vu le niveau n avait vu le niveau
de tension évidemment et d'attentes qui
avait à la proche de la cérémonie vous
doutez bien que je me suis permis à
préparer un apu tain je suis là ta came
as je suis rapproché je me suis permis à
préparer déjà physiquement c'est à dire
que j'ai j'ai j'ai fait très attention à
mon hygiène de vie j'ai réduit ma
consommation d'alcool donc je suis très
en forme j'ai même faire un break jeanne
uhari enfin j'ai voulu faire un vrai
génie arrive j'ai fait un drap yesterday
mais ouais non mais j'ai pas vu hier
c'est déjà cédé jacques annaud je me
suis totalement détoxifier de
l'intérieur mais également de
l'extérieur
jacqueline et tout mon passé numérique
aux siens 1 j'ai effacé tous milieux
tweets
j'ai vidé mon cloud j'ai nettoyé ma
photothèque gtoi ouais y'a plus une
seule photo de moi en blackface en train
de faire un salut nazi dans mon
téléphone +1 et pourtant dieu sait que
c'est ma passion non mais enfin c'est là
c'est là dedans tu sais j'ai plus de
traces mais celle là non je suis
inattaquable et alors en revanche pardon
je suis désolé j'ai rien pu faire j'ai
essayé je suis confuse semblerait que ce
soit blanche et héros des rita chrétien
alors là c'est pas grave parce que je
suis une femme quand même donc c'est bon
ça a enfin en même temps j'ai en
préménopause du coup je sais pas si ça
compte encore plus de 2000 femmes moitié
de femmes
et puis bon je suis blanche à l'ag du
sont italiens dont je suis un peu arabe
en vrai nom mais les [ __ ] on est un
peu des arabes volent vers donc c'est
bon pas deux milliards et demi femme je
pense que ça ça vous ira par contre
alors vu le contexte évidemment j'ai
fait très attention à mes textes aussi
ne vous inquiétez pas vous pouvez rire
tranquillement à l'écran non je vous
doutez bien que j'allais pas laisser
faut faire j'avais pas laisser [ __ ] en
l'air 15 ans de carrière à cause d'un
petit concert son smartphone un ou d'une
association manque de buzz donc j'ai
fait très très attention j'ai pas envie
de me retrouver en top tweets et
compagnie mais c'est aussi pour vous en
effet comme ça à l'écran sur les plans
de coupe
vous verrez vous serez jamais taxé de
rire complice quoi je veux dire voilà
vous pouvez vous vous êtes même pas
obligé de m'écouter on pourra regarder
les vidéos de chats sur internet vous
marrer je serai jamais voilà vous serez
jamais embêtés hein sur les réseaux
sociaux
voilà on est sur du rire bio ce soir
dury oui du riverain glyphosate vraiment
allez-y je vais être qu'on sent suel
c'est pour vous hein
voilà je vraiment jeu je me prendrai
aucun risque il y aura aucune blague sur
les minorités aucune blague sur les
handicapés sur les femmes / / / les
noirs sur les paysans sur les végal et
les transsexuels les animaux personnes
et les cafetières je trouve pas que j'ai
fait un peu de bruit quand on veut on
l'a fait on a pu marcher non c'est
certain on va s'ennuyer non médiation
pour que soient totalement tranquille il
faut le dire il faut que vous faut qu'on
règle un dossier pour être totalement
sinon il ya un moment où on va avoir un
souci
il ya douze moment où vabre
alors je pose la question il convenu il
faut qu'on règle le problème sinon ça
pourrir la soirée donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait qu'est qu'on fait avec eux accro
donc on fait avec elle propose un nom
alors ne faites pas comme lui faites pas
les innocents vous savez très bien de
qui je parle
qu'est qu'on fait quatum non mais je
veux dire on applaudit on n'applaudit
pas vous qu'on se mette d'accord parce
que vous êtes d'accord jeudi lors de
questions que j'assume ça tout seuls de
très sain très sympathique je vous aime
beaucoup mais vous fait reculer
que
moi moi ça va quelque quarante trois ans
après les faits je veux pas réglé le
problème comme ça je veux dire moi à
l'époque à faire au moment des faits les
trois ans je suis à lyon tu penn-ar-pont
en plein stade anal en train d'essayer
de faire entrer car elles enverront le
voilà lui hollywood au même stade
on traite pas oui ça peut durer est en
train d'essayer de faire qu'il ya rennes
et et je devrais me retrouver juge
d'application des peines non je suis
désolé je ne suis pas là greta von baer
du cinéma français anthérieu moi je m'en
fous je n'ai pas de prix m'en fous c'est
pour vous
katie katie qui vous avez affaire abah
vous vouliez la démocratie directe vous
en avez un
moi de mon côté je vais vous dire j'ai
tout réglé moi de mon côté j'ai j'ai
décidé qu'à tchoum n'étaient pas assez
grands pour faire de l'ombre au cinéma
français et on reste de la sélection
c'est pourquoi je vous demande
d'applaudir les dix nominations pour
portrait de la jeune fille en feu de
céline sciamma s'il vous plaît
en trop
avec un casting exclusivement féminin
une équipe technique à majorité féminine
bravo pour quelqu'un du collectif 55 ans
ça serait sympa de voilà on est plutôt
sur du 80/20 là pour le voir après
rentrée testostérone plus banal je lui
dis ça compense parce qu'on a les
misérables avec 11 nominations juste à
côté que des hommes c'est qu'on a quand
même parce que vous auriez fait un film
ensemble
la gc l'inonder portrait des misérables
enfants ont coché toutes les cases ont
été pénalisés par un char est plus qu'un
nom était inattaquable
alors gare aux dominations aussi pour
mon ami nicolas bedos et la belle époque
[Applaudissements]
alors la belle époque magnifique alors
magnifique c'est l'histoire de pitch
très simple c'est l'histoire d'un homme
qui qui retourne un rassemblement dans
le passé pour pour revivre sa rencontre
avec sa femme alors lui alors il va dans
le passé mais lui reste lui de son âge
mais la femme du prince et palabres fc
lucas 30 ans de moins que les quelque
chose scénario mais alors oui attend pas
fini pas de câble le réalisateur de tout
ça pas nicolas lemay le marionnettiste
dans le clip guillaume canet il touche
et que la fille qui joue la mère mais
avec 30 au moins comme ça et ça permet
au père le héros de retomber amoureux de
sa femme mais de via la jeune comment
c'est vrai cette analyse nicolas on en
est où
c'est finit bientôt montrait bien entubé
si tu cherches quelqu'un pour pitcher
ton prochain film
alors là tu n'hésites pas on peut me
dire également arnaud despléchin c'est
cette nomination prouve un libyen
bobet muller enfin un film au pitch qui
tient en une phrase qui cas être angelus
est heureusement bois alors c'est pas
rien houzé claude amassés par mois non
c'était pour faire un extrait pour ceux
qui n'avaient pas vu non mais c'est un
film qui traite de la misère sociale
d'ailleurs évidemment comme comme chaque
année toute la sélection toute la
sélection des films nommés n'ont pas
peur c'est des films qui n'ont pas peur
de regarder la société en face et de
traiter des grands grands sujets les
grands mots notre société au nom de la
terre qui traite du suicide dans le
monde agricole atlantique la cause
immigrants bien sûr grâce à dieu grâce à
dieu la pédophilie dans l'église
j'accuse la pédophilie dans les années
70 hors norme
l'autisme est le plus grave nous
finirons ensemble la flambée des prix de
l'immobilier au cap ferret bien
[Applaudissements]